et
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est voumard
youssef soliman bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
poètes écrivains syriens en exil
français depuis peu vous vivez ici
depuis une dizaine d'années vous avez
fui la répression dans votre pays une
chambre en exil qui hélas est votre
troisième roman publié chez flammarion
qui dit beaucoup de vous et de votre
parcours la sortie de ce livre a été
pour vous un événement important
j'imagine de cette année on va y revenir
dans un instant il a eu un autre moment
plus personnel je crois il y à une
quinzaine de jours l'élection
présidentielle ici en france non
seulement c'était la première fois que
vous votiez en france à la faveur de
votre naturalisation mais c'était aussi
a dit vous la première fois de votre vie
que ce vote avait du sens je te fais
donc c'était un cadeau de la vie c'était
incroyable pourra syrien qui vient puis
a passé la majorité de sa vie dans une
dans un pays est dirigé par un régime
dictatorial ils rentrent ici en france
comme vous avez dit ça fait dix ans que
je vis ici et pour moi c'était c'était
la fête à la fin vous savez les syriens
ils ont ils ont la facture syrienne
était très très cher pour arriver à ce
moment ce qu'on appelle la démocratie
choisir son président choisira son
parlement c'était la raison principale
pour laquelle
on a regardé cette révolution syrienne
en 2001 en 2011 skis l'aube ce qui est
paradoxal c'est qu après toutes ces
années d'exil après tout cette facture
très très cher qu'on avait pays on vote
à l'étranger avec une nouvelle
nationalité dans mon nouveau pays qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle la france donc
j'étais tellement émue et à la fois je
regrette de ne pas appliquer cette
démocratie dans mon pays d'origine la
syrie de fierté de tristesse on imagine
parce que vous venez de vous venez
effectivement vous n'avez pas compris qu
autant de français ne soient pas allés
voter tout à fait vous savez qu'à
caroline est dans un pays de démocratie
on débat comme ça quel privilège on a
dans ce pays j'ai pas mal d'amis qui ont
refusé de voter ou qu'ils ont elles sont
désespérés vis-à-vis de l'avenir
français et surtout ce après la réaction
après la le premier tour so clients dit
ni macro ni le pen je n'étais pas du
tout d'accord parce qu un 2 2 enfin
passer toute façon et on a toujours
cette fenêtre qui s'appelle la
démocratie qui donne vers un avenir
meilleur
je pense il faut profiter de de la
démocratie dans notre pays dans ce roman
une chambre en exil vous fait dire à
votre héros qui est comme vous réfugiés
syriens lui il est installé
temporairement à bobigny on va y revenir
c'est à côté de paris en
seine-saint-denis je cite ce que vous
écrivez un des premiers mots de français
que j'ai appris avec fait chier
c'est j'en ai marre se plaindre fait
partie de la culture française un
étrangers venus du moyen-orient on
remarque cette façon de réagir pour lui
ce penchant pour le malheur n'a pas de
sens parce qu'il a connu une autre vie
celle d'un pays sans sécurité sociale
sans liberté d'expression sans
démocratie pour savoir à quel point on
vit bien en france il suffit de vivre
ailleurs est ce que vous direz que les
français sont ingrats vous savez c'est
râler c'est fait partie de notre culture
française et justement comme j'ai obtenu
la nationalité il y a quelques mois j'ai
commencé draps les eaux
contaminées par se plaindre mais c'est
pour être cool ils ont râlé ce n'est pas
quelque chose de méchant mais sur
l'autre côté vous savez ces dernières
années j'ai fréquenté pas mal des
français et des françaises qui font
partie des mouvements de gilet jaune une
fois qu'ils savaient que je venais de la
syrie il me disait quoi non aussi envie
chez unique tu as tu remets une
dictature masquée et ça a répété blue
tard avec ce qu'on appelle la dictature
de pas sanitaire la dictature sanitaire
la dictature à moi je suis je trouve qu
c c'est un discours tellement absurde
complètement et c'est très très
dangereux pour la france bat sco et ça
donne une l'assaut de l'illimité de
régime syrien quand on compare macro
avec mes chats avec mais charles à 7 qui
a tué plus que cinq cent mille personnes
de son immeuble et de plus le blue
dangereux pour la france vis-à-vis son
discours c'est qu on bave à renverser
une dictature par de manière pacifique
souvent donc on se demande pourquoi ces
gens insiste convient dans un bis dirigé
bas régime dictatorial est-ce qu'ils
invitent à prendre des armes
cette somme en exil est un roman
d'apprentissage donc celui d'un réfugié
qui se retrouvent confrontés à ce qui la
fuit en réalité dans son pays le
fanatisme religieux vous qui ne
croyaient plus en dieu depuis votre
adolescence qui avait vu en syrie les
ravages que le fanatisme fait est ce que
c'est de ça dont vous avez été frappée à
votre arrivée en france par le par le
poids de la religion vous savez
aujourd'hui
montre ma seule comme unité c'est l'exil
parce qu'il ne faut à koné exilé au
nigeria vit une fois qu'ils sont tombés
à bobigny dû chercher à trouver une
nouvelle la vie oublier la violence
oubliez de là
les islamistes oubliée la radicalisation
de la guerre et s'est retrouvé à nouveau
un nouveau travail peut-être trouvé
l'amour de sa vie scola narrateur
raconte dans une chambre en exil mais
une fois qu'il tombe sur cette ville qui
s'appelle bobigny il est choqué barre
des scènes inattendues c'est à dire des
fillettes voilées de nova dix ans
c'était même dans les villages
fanatiques on trouve pas ça en syrie on
le trouve mais très très rarement les
imams qui récupère certains quartiers
qui sont devenus les porte parole de ces
quartiers je trouve que c'était c'était
tellement dangereux parce que ces imams
suit et suivent un blanc qui était
qu'ils étaient
lancés par les frères musulmans dans les
années 80-90 partout en europe pour
réunir les musulmans autour une identité
qui s'appelle l'islam et les séparer de
leur propre pays ici la france où ou
ailleurs ce qu'on avait vécu des eaux
d'ailleurs dans les pays arabes depuis
les années 40 surtout surtout en egypte
donc ce que le narrateur raconte parce
que quand il rate quand il rencontre les
imams de bobigny ce qu'il m'est arrivé
il le balance ce plan parce qu'il les
traite comme un migrant es bas comme en
france et donc ils ont un autre discours
avec lui ouais vous montrer en
personnage qui est votre double qui ne
trouve pas sa place qui se heurtent je
vous cite à une communauté arabe centré
sur l'islam à une certaine gauche qui ne
veut pas voir la radicalisation qui a
cours en france et qui accuse qui vous
accusent qui accuse votre narrateur
d'être récupéré par l'extrême droite
c'est sans échappatoire tout à fait jb
cette gauche la gauche halal parce que
malheureusement il ya un sort de
complicité entre elle et les islamistes
de la france aux normes de se défendre
contre l'extrême droite contre les
capitalistes contre les impérialistes
ils n'ont pas de problème de serrer les
mains des assassins ou des sports des
islamistes qui sont en grand danger pour
notre pays ce qui lui arrive souvent
quand je critique les islamistes en
france où le plat tout le monde qui sont
venus de de cet enfer qui s'appelle
les islamistes tu parles de moyen orient
ils sont ils sont accusés ici en france
de cette partie de la gauche comme des
gens soient comme des traîtres soit
comme des gens
récupéré par par alexander escaut le
narrateur souffre d'ailleurs par une 1/2
personnage qui s'appelle eva qui est
d'extrême gauche la gauche sera la halle
encore une fois et la cuisse tout le
temps d'être petits de ne pas comprendre
qu'est-ce que c'est la france c'est elle
qui comprend que celles qui savent pas
ce que le traite comme un migrant un
beau ignorant il n'a pas le droit de
bail de certains sujets et à mon avis
est parti de gauche pratiquant sort du
racisme d'une manière ou d'autre c'est à
dire ils sont ils ont ils interdisent
certains certaines personnes de parler
ici on fera d'exprimer aux normes de
protéger la liberté d'expression où la
démocratie française sûr que c'est un
boost qui s'offraient comme il y a un
peu plus de 11 ans le 11 mars 2011
débuté la révolution syrienne à laquelle
vous avez participé
la guerre en syrie ne fait plus les gros
titres aujourd'hui de l'actualité omar
youssef souleimane cette révolution a
été réprimé par bachar el-assad avec une
violence sans limite à ce qu'une
président syrien
et barlow par ray charles à 7 et par les
riches on va y revenir un instant voilà
donc le régime serait annaba gagner à
mon avis parce que c'est ce régime avant
d'y la syrie pour pour les russes et
pour les iraniens
ils ont aujourd'hui même les polices la
police qui contrôle la vie quotidienne
qui contrôle tout en série le service de
renseignement sont blues' riant donc il
n'a pas gagné peut-être la mafia dans
l'appel le régime en syrie a gagné juste
certains quartiers où ils font semblant
qu'ils ont toujours le pouvoir le blue
dangereux vous savez il y a deux
semaines environ il y avait une vidéo
qui documentent à un crime commis en
2013 avec les visages des soldats qui
ont massacré quarantine seville s'est
rétracté une personne de civils de damas
c'était très clair dans la vidéo quillan
j'étais dans un trou puis ils ont brûlé
le
les canards c'est horrible c'est comme
complètement monstrueux et donc ça c'est
une des vidéos des milliers de vidéos
qu'on a des couteaux qui monte il avait
cette guerre horrible et malheureusement
et aucun jugement le régime est toujours
nîmes mois sur glace et on attend de lui
qu'il soit jugé pascoe peut-être le bal
de la majorité des syriens ils ont blood
espoirs est-ce qu'on l'a mal la seule
façon qu'aux régimes départ c'est la
force aérienne
les sévillans sont seuls face à ce
régime en angola la guerre en syrie vous
à rappeler votre guerre à vous en ce
sens que vous dites avoir un ennemi
commun avec les ukrainien vladimir
poutine bien sûr il ya une complicité
une solidarité incroyable entre les
syriens et les craignants aujourd'hui
beaucoup de syriens ont envie d aller en
ukraine pour résister parce qu on a le
même combat on a le même ennemi qui
s'appelle poutine poutine a sauvé en
2014 et en 2015
a détruit des villes entières en syrie
alep est devenu d'erwin à cause des
russes ce qu'on a vu que ce qu'on a vu
récemment un mario paul ou ailleurs
le crâne est aussi l'exil l'exil dont
peut pas savoir ce que c'est lorsqu'on
vit et donc on a aujourd'hui 5 millions
craignant qu'ils sont devenus dépendants
de
quelques mois et on a jusqu'au 7
millions syriens qui sont exilés à le à
l'extérieur de la syrie donc on partage
cette douleur et on partage aussi le
même ennemi on partage de même humanité
je crois vis-à-vis cette guerre est
justement à propos d' exile on voulait
vous donner l'occasion aux mario c'est
fou les mânes de lire un de vos poèmes
que vous avez écrit dans cette belle
blonde qu'elle français que vous parlez
merveilleusement n'y en ait que vous
écrivez incroyablement bien
plaisir je ne sais plus s'il nous reste
un récit au coeur des miroirs ou encore
à l'enfant oublié
lancre et blanches dans nos artères ce
que nous croyons connaître nous
l'ignorons et d'écolo signons n'est de
nous à neko anonyme il se mêle à l'odeur
de la nuit de mars entre la poudre à
canon et les larmes
quand je grandirai je serai une étoile
ainsi parle la trace de la balle les
cédants de la chaire il nous vous
servira à rien d'ouvrir mes brouillons
et de guitare en compagnie des nuages
jusqu'à mon retour
qu'un seul exil et appelle ses frères et
le soir se blesse
merci beaucoup il ya un autre poème dans
votre livre en filigrane c'est celui de
paul eluard liberté créé en 1942 en
clandestinité
merci beaucoup d'être venu nous parler
de ce livre est de votre parcours ce
matin une chambre en exil donc qui est
sorti à quelques semaines chez
flammarion merci beaucoup
très bonne journée à vous